all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with Defenders
Beyond and this is the conclusion and
yes the one above all makes his return
now this story is going to shift up
everything you know about the one above
all and I love the way that it's done
right so in the last video that we did
we basically picked up with kind of the
conclusion of that little bit of a story
that the Defenders were effectively
moving to what was called the house of
ideas now this is a phrase that Al Ewing
is using both in terms of the story but
as well as the real world and the reason
why is because Marvel Comics used to be
called the house of ideas that was kind
of their great big huge tag name and so
with that being the case once Adam
Brashear gets in here and he's met by
the one above all he's basically given
the same line that more or less the one
above all gives most everybody right I
see through many eyes I build with many
hands they are themselves but they are
also me I am all powerful my only weapon
is love the mystery intrigues me I am as
I am I will be what I will be I am the
one above all now to that Adam Brashears
just kind of like I don't think that's
true now that's one of the crazy things
about this is because in response to
that the one above all launches an
attack against them using all these
different monsters now here's the cool
thing about this if you're familiar with
Marvel Comics this is actually Al ewing
using Marvel's publishing history and
then bringing it into the comic book and
the reason why I say that is because
those of you guys who are not really
familiar with the history of Marvel long
before Marvel was Marvel you had timely
Comics timely Comics is where you got
Jack Kirby and Joe Simon who created
like Captain America right Captain
America Comics number one now one
superhero stopped being popular after
World War II timely Comics changed its
name to Atlas Comics and what Atlas
Comics did which is really where Stan
Lee got his start Atlas Comics was
focusing on science fiction monsters
different things like that it wasn't
until the 1960s with really Fantastic
Four number one that Marvel Comics
became the Marvel Comics that we know
and this is so cool because these
monsters you're seeing here these are
the old stories that Marvel published
before superheroes emerge so it's really
one of these things where it's kind of
alewing offering this kind of commentary
and saying like the one above all has
always existed it's always been around
it's been since the beginning of
everything and so these monsters that
it's spewing up are the creatures that
existed before like the Multiverse
exists as it exists now which is why
they're kind of referred to as like the
beast from before or whatever the case
happens to be now the Defenders are able
to get the upper hand on these guys
pretty quickly and for the most part
they're able to kind of take them out
but these beings are pretty powerful and
so in the midst of all this what you do
is you have Adam Brashear who says I
don't believe in any God who tests their
Creations I've been tested enough all of
humanity has but I do believe in a God
who questions us and who asks us to
question them and that's when the one
above all stops and it simply says then
speak if you have understanding and so
this is where things get amazing right
because what Adam Brashear says here
really he says like there's no power
that we can reach above yours you're as
high as we can go that's what defines
you but does that truly make you above
all he says this is only the beginning
of the journey isn't it beginning of
what you represent and what creates
creation now this is the thing because
his question right or his statement what
creates creation that's where the one
above all responds this says the place
where the world of action ends and the
world of creation begins so for those of
you guys who are unfamiliar the one
above all in Marvel Comics has
historically been the top person right
and different depictions of the one
above all have taken place for example
there was a story with a Fantastic Four
met the one above all and the one above
all was depicted as Jack Kirby there's
been instances where it's been eluded
that the one above all has is basically
Stan Lee there was a point where the one
above all appeared to Peter Parker and
did not look like Stan Lee or Jack Kirby
so the one above all has always been
kind of depicted as just this
exceedingly powerful being and is the
creation or the reason why all things
exist there's even this idea that the
one above all is basically Marvel
publishing right the the kind of
combination of the writers the artists
the editors the editor-in-chief
everybody who decides what gets
published in Marvel but what Adel Ewing
is doing here is he's putting forward
this idea that the cosmic hierarchy as
we've seen it up to this point the
Phoenix Force beyonder so on and so
forth that's all just the tangible realm
right that's a being out there who's
really powerful and can do some stuff
what the one above all represents is the
entrance into a whole nother level of
hierarchy that exists out there as far
as people who create things right those
individuals who are capable of creation
that when you have someone like the one
above all everybody who exists
throughout the entirety of the Marvel
Multiverse would be powerless in the
face of the one above all because all it
has to do is just wipe them from
existence and there's no conceivable
means of bringing them back unless the
one above all chooses to that's the way
its character always operated but what
Al Ewing is doing is saying the one
above all is just the first in a new
line of just these astronomically
powerful Cosmic beings that exist out
there that are in charge of creating
everything and so it's a really really
awesome concept because this is a level
of power we've never seen before and so
again where you have Adam or Shear
talking with the one above all and
asking what creates creation above
everything even your creators is there a
final guiding hand can there be do you
know one above all the response is the
mystery intrigues me Adam I have my
answers from you what do you wish from
me and so that's when you kind of get
this sort of statement this made right
each one kind of asking for something in
particular Taya wants to know what's
going on with her son right Galactus
becoming the world of hour because
remember she comes from the universe
where Galactus originated before he ever
became Galactus but what the one above
all says here is Taya your son becomes
the Devourer of Worlds right he's born
into your reality as your son your
universe and the Multiverse will
basically end it'll be reborn and he
will be born into the new universe and
even a new Multiverse as Galactus this
is by my design I intended it to be this
way so it's not some kind of grand
Cosmic mistake despite the fact that it
shocked you to learn that your son would
become a person that just eradicates
entire worlds in the new universe it's
just how I wanted things to be and he
says but you cannot return to your
Cosmos with that knowledge now of course
America Chavez asks about her sister Al
Ewing's responses you will find her and
more nothing that we was made as ever
lost America Chavez Tigra kind of wants
to know what her purpose is and the one
above all is just like you have no real
purpose team and so as a result of that
you basically have this really cool
instance where Adam Brashear asked the
question okay the Defenders have a
mission to complete we were charged by
eternity to travel into the cosmos and
to find this Grand Cosmic threat and so
far we found nothing we've only found a
hierarchy of cosmic beings what's this
Grand threat and what the one above all
says and this is this is going to be
mind-boggling insane the one above all
says behold and take what you can
understand the Grail at the end of your
quest is a single glimpse of the Enigma
to come and so what they're looking at
here to the best of their ability to
interpret it is simply just a giant
crown that stretches across all things
that exist and literally Adam Brashear
says it's a crown above all things and
so he simply says it's up to us to
decode the cosmic symbolism so basically
Al yuming is just like there is a source
of power that exists out there that is
beyond the one above all but at the end
of the day you're gonna have to wait to
find out what it is
because I'm not going to tell you now as
most people are suspecting this is only
the second part in the trilogy that you
have the defender's comic which was
written by Al Ewing this is part two
which is you could argue it is like The
Empire Strikes Back of the defender's
comic terrible analogy I know just go
with me on that but then part three will
be the Return of the Jedi but hopefully
it'll be better than the movie but it'll
be like the part three that kind of
wraps everything up but it's one of
those interesting Concepts because in
that moment Loki chimes in and says okay
so here's the thing in our Quest we were
all brought together by basically the
soul of Doctor Strange we were shown a
crown on the tarot cards so this is the
threat that we have to find some way to
defeat But ultimately we have no earthly
clue how to do this we have no earthly
clue how to pull this off and so what
Loki actually reveals is that the coming
together of the Defenders as it exists
while it was orchestrated by Doctor
Strange Loki went along with it because
what Loki seeks to do is to actually
leave that the power of the realm of the
one above all is that because it exists
out there in the space where things are
created it exists outside the Multiverse
Loki seeks to believe everything walk
away from the Multiverse to Whole Nine
Yards you could make a convincing
argument here that what Loki's saying is
he wants to enter basically into the
real world he wants to leave the world
of fiction and enter into the real world
now the funny thing about this is that
what we're also really giving here is
that while the Defenders don't
necessarily get into a big conversation
about it they're all basically coming to
this realization they're fictional
characters their stories are guaranteed
the things that happen in their lives
happen because they're supposed to
because they were created that way right
Adam brochure facing off against
anti-man Connor Sims Loki and all his
stories America Chavez and so on and so
forth it's all pre-written it's like
when Deadpool discovered that he was a
fictional character it's just that
they're not killing the entirety of the
Marvel Universe but it's a cool thing
because of course the Beyond or
seemingly shows up out of nowhere in the
midst of all this but the idea behind it
is that you do have Loki kind of given
this idea that he could legitimately
just leave it's an opportunity available
to him that he could just walk away he
could leave the Omniverse the Multiverse
step out into the real world but the
other part of this is that Anna Bashir
chimes in and with was something that's
known as the bat he said The Vow now I'm
probably butchering the hell out of that
pronunciation I apologize if I am but
the entire idea behind this vow is the
at least as far as the story goes is
that you had somebody named City Garba I
think is how you pronounce that again
I'm terrible when it comes to
pronunciations like that but this person
vowed not to attain buddhahood until all
Hells were emptied because there is no
Enlightenment until all are enlightened
there is no Freedom until all are free
and so the important thing here and this
is what's kind of nuts about this the
kind of stuff Al Ewing's throwing out
here the Revelation by Adam Brashear and
the Defenders that their fictional
characters Loki trying to leave and walk
away right this idea of of a statement
being made directly to Loki that that at
the end of the day he's like reality
wants me in some old shape it wants me
to be what I used to be and the kind of
counter statement being like do you
think that it can God of stories like do
you think it didn't try that kind of
situation this is all moving or all kind
of pointing towards the idea of a
massive paradigm shift in Marvel Comics
that this notion of what they're kicking
off or at least what they're alluding to
is some massive reworking of the
landscape and the reason why I say that
is because all of this puts forward the
idea that the Defenders themselves
accessing the realm of the one above all
learning the fictional history of
characters it can all be changed it can
be Rewritten that they are given a
status quo but they can leave the status
quo they can alter the status quo they
can change what they want their stories
to be it kind of smells like a bit of a
reboot to a degree now I don't know if
that's gonna happen it's probably me
just as a Marvel Comics fan saying like
it's high time you guys reboot we know
that like Jonathan Hickman and Marvel
are working on something massive coming
out in 2023 this year is supposed to
happen in the summer I don't know if
it's going to be a reboot Marvel needs
to reboot Mariah literally just finished
Secret Wars and I asked her doesn't that
story end where it felt like it was
supposed to be a reboot and she's like
yeah do they reboot and I was like nope
and she's like that sucks because it
feels like they were supposed to reboot
like it it's kind of what it feels like
to me but again it may just be me as the
person wanting Marvel to reboot kind of
feeding my own desire right but the
important thing is that the beyonder
himself had actually gone along with
this whole thing just to see if he could
that the reality of the beyonder is that
it doesn't want to go back to the second
Cosmos it doesn't want to go back to its
place where it just hangs around and
waits until something pops off with the
celestials and the beyonders have to
step in that it doesn't really give us a
whole lot of expose until like their
mindset regarding Secret Wars The
Avengers The New Avengers run by
Jonathan Hickman the collapse of the
Multiverse but what it does say is this
desire is to literally leave everything
in creation and see what all is out
there to see if it could possibly even
just create its own thing and so what
happens is this realm is basically
destroyed by the beyonder and then it
literally takes off into Parts Unknown
we have no idea where his story goes and
it could very well be the beyonder does
achieve a whole new level of power
whether Beyond or potentially even takes
the power of the one above all which is
just downright scary but the thing about
this is this Al Ewing kind of setting
the seeds for all these different
character stories going forward right
Loki still has the eternity mask and
while he does end up traveling back to
Earth he goes back to his place what
this means is that with eternity's mask
his power is equal to whoever he faces
off against if he fights the one above
all his power becomes equal to the one
above all that's how the eternity mask
works there's no limit to it and while
you do have Taya who was supposed to go
back to her reality the response of Adam
Brashear is but the one above all didn't
say when all the one above all said is
that you cannot go back to your Universe
with knowledge of what your son becomes
because you may warn your son you may
stop him from becoming Galactus whatever
the case happens to be these things kind
of have to happen because the character
exists therefore the circumstances must
exist for him to exist the way that he
does and so she basically just kind of
lingers around she becomes a part of the
defender she effectively joins the team
but again AL Ewing leaves it open-ended
he's just like yeah I mean they haven't
found like they know it's the crown but
they don't know what it means and they
haven't really found the main enemy
itself it's just kind of a glimpse of
what awaits them so what it looks like
is going into presumably this
quote-unquote third part of the
defender's story things are going to be
crazy and we're gonna end up coming
across Cosmic entities with stupid
levels of power that we didn't even know
existed but for but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end let me know what you think about
this change with the one above all and I
will catch you all later
peace